[Musique]
après sept années de fonder ni nous
pensons qu'il y a vraiment tout 1 1
une action sociale à mener il faut
continuer à se mobiliser et l'action
sociale c'est le coeur du département
c'est le coeur de sa mission cette crise
doit être va encore avoir des effets et
nous devons être mobilisés pour aider
tous les habitants les commerces les
jeunes il y a beaucoup à faire
je n'accepte pas la position qui a été
prise dans notre département de donner
l'investiture à un maire qui ne soutient
pas valérie pécresse à la région par
exemple et donc c'est aussi une des
raisons de mon engagement mon engagement
sera axée principalement sur ce sol
enseignements sur les collèges est sûre
et sur les infrastructures les routes
les routes par exemple puisque puisque
c'est un un sujet que je connais bien
puisque j'ai été j'étais ingénieur eaux
territoriales sur les routes
départementales notamment
[Musique]
on a bien vu la baisse des subventions
même presque la disparition de beaucoup
de subventions au sport et à la culture
donc pour nous c'est un point important
mois les associations c'est cher à mon
coeur et je pense que c'est vraiment le
coeur des villes c'est ça qui fait le
vivre ensemble
les subventions c'est quelque chose
d'important mais il ya aussi les pays en
matière d'enfance qui font un peu défaut
en ce moment et notre volonté c'est
d'essayer de remettre en ordre ses
points de vue là pour ce qui est de la
c5 vous et du collège
c'est un projet qui devait voir le jour
à la rentrée prochaine
qui finalement ne verra pas le jour à la
rentrée prochaine j'ai bien l'intention
de m'investir à fond et de vraiment
travailler sur tous ces dossiers comme
le collège pasteur comme bougival comme
les infrastructures à bali donc voilà
c'est vraiment travailler avec les
maires à 100% pour ave pour faire
avancer les dossiers au niveau des
départements
notre volonté c'est d'être en contact
direct avec les habitants et de l'or
entre guillemets rendre compte de nos de
nos actions et ça fait partie d'une
proposition de mettre en place une sorte
de de perdre permanence vous nous avez
face à vous à 4 nous sommes quatre sur
l'affiché nous le resterons là c'est à
dire que il ya effectivement un binôme
titulaires qui sera élu mais le binôme
remplaçant ou suppléants sera toujours
présent et associés est associée au
travail